l'échec fait partie de ma vie comme du
succès et si tu as peur d'avoir 10 10 et
chic c'est là où tu peux pas avoir du
succès la différence en ce que je fais
est peut-être quelqu'un qui travaille
dans un bureau c'est que si j'ai un
échec je peux perdre ma vie
en 2006 quand j'étais au pôle pour la
première fois et à 10 jours dit paul
gellé mes doigts et j'ai invité mes
doigts dans dans la tente pour essayer
d'arriver d'avancé et puis après j'ai
chopé des gangrènes et mes doigts a
commencé de puer et puis dans la tente
je pensais comme enjeu veut cacher ça
c'est échec c'est terrible je suis à dix
jours du pôle et j'arrive pas j'appelle
ma femme par téléphone de sa qualité
jeudi mais cathy j'ai gelé mais doit g
je commence à avoir des gangs rivaux
trinh duc on prend les dix doigts pourri
ça commence depuis mais je pense que
pour pas voir l'échec
je veux continuer avec la possibilité de
me faire amputer le bras
et puis elle elle m'a dit mais tu es
complètement taré ou quoi comment tu
penses que tu peux faire quelque chose
et tu vas rentrer à la maison
atteignons un nombre sans bras parce que
tu as peur de gérer l'échec tu as peur
de ce que disent on va dire pour moi ça
c'est le plus grand des chèques l'échec
c'est ce que tu as essayé de faire c'est
un échec mais maicon iris maicon avec
l'énergie avec l' envie de gagner avec
les idées un peu fou mais des projets
peut avoir un échec c'est pour ça tu
dois avoir la possibilité
de s'éloigner de faire la différence
entre un projet qui peut éventuellement
avoir un échec
et toi qu'on perd ça que j'essaye de
grands pedica 2 par exemple comme j'ai
grimpé déjà trois fois j'ai jamais
arrivée au sommet de la montagne
chaque fois quand je rentre pour tout le
monde qui regarde qui vit pas autour de
nous asséner chèque on n'a pas arriver
vers notre but mais pour moi les succès
c'est de rester vivant de rentrer vivant
au camp basque je peux essayer ça veut
dire que lis les échecs permanente comme
quand j'ai perdu ma femme c'est pas
c'est pas toi qui as qui a décidé
qu'elle est plus là mais c'est plutôt en
fait les explications que j'ai eu à la
vie de penser qu'on va vivre pour
toujours et ça c'est un échec de mes
pensées et c'est pour ça je dis il faut
il faut vivre au moment présent il faut
faire le maximum de choses possibles
avait dit avec les gens qu'on aime et il
faut pas repousser ça dans la vie parce
que ça c'est la vrai échec